[Music]
[Music]
easy
[Applause]
are you ready kids
i can't hear you
[Music]
be sure not to tell your dad what i did
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
stranger
that's a bad story i'm tired of doing
the slurp for you because you're
ungrateful it's not even morning really
i always want to hear those noises at
the movies
yes well that's the last time you go uh
to the pee wee herman theater what's his
name always forget his paul rubin
paul rubins uh oh this is uh we've
already by the way dave lando had not
seen the biden grab out so he was
positively tickled
i was laughing very hard this is uh
because we are all children
this is our first uh live stream of an
event this year yeah
we were planning on doing it we were
planning on doing it just like we had
done with the debates in town halls
but there have been no press conferences
with joe biden we've been waiting with
bated breath
and i'm not gonna burn all my powder on
saki no no no no
no no you can't you can't fight someone
who doesn't have a soul it's like
dueling with the immortals um so today
we do have a promo code for you where
you get twenty dollars off
mug club uh promo code dimension
dementia okay
also use the hashtag by the way we're
not insinuating anything no no
it's to raise money for those who uh
waste them
watch mug who may have dementia it's an
acronym yes
and the promo the hashtag is a crowded
biden stream we're going to be watching
the
the live uh i guess it's not really a
town hall it's a press conference this
shouldn't be an event
it really shouldn't it should be it
should be a common daily occurrence
however it is not uh and uh we have a
drinking game right we do
have a drinking game so that you can
watch along with us so when you see
any of these words can you read them
jeremy shut the arm yeah
or seven shootings in seven days
number three asked easy or leading
question number four biden tells a
blatant liar number five biden stutters
and you hear this ding
that means that it's time for you to get
slashed and of course uh dave landau is
a can
yeah he doesn't drink no no i'm in
recovery but this would even kill an
alcoholic like me and my best friend
good luck so be safe out there yes yes
and by be safe we mean uh join my club
blow out of the clutter.com
club what can we expect today look this
is what i think we can expect okay and
then we're going to uh go through a
couple of clips couple of montages
and then we'll have a a long post show
for you if you could bring up a cnn that
lower third so people can see that
they'll be
watching it along with us post show will
probably be longer than the press
conference i expect it to be shorter the
average press conference with donald
trump was about an hour um i expect this
to be half an hour to an hour i expect
him to talk about
uh migrants i expect him to of course
talk about mass shootings and try and
push h.r 127.
and of course we expect him to uh
obviously try and tout
his victory with the pandemic despite
the fact that 1.3 million vaccines were
delivered under donald trump in january
an average of one million a day
uh what by the way we have gerald a
quarterblack dave landau you can follow
all of them what do you expect here
today
i i expect softball questions i expect
him to kind of bounce back and forth and
nobody to call him on any of this stuff
right yeah
i don't i don't think reporters are
really doing their jobs very well right
now we are seeing
some start to ask pro fascinating
insight captain but
this that guy jean shalit who shaved his
mustache and ate a bunch of cake
who is that it seems to me that the
chasm between
biden and the population widens
which is why we need a press conference
and i don't know how to finish this
rhyme because i'm about on par with bind
intellectually
it's old josh gad yes that's all scared
from the future i predict to freeze too
i predicted at one moment he's just
gonna go
yep well he's going to lose the train
he mispronounced the first word which
was tonight and he said
to light but he said it's not just that
he said well he thought he was coming to
the light
the light i think he was he was yes then
they stabbed him with an epipen full of
norepinephrine
like sherlock holmes with watson's dog
tonight tonight tonight yeah sucked him
right back into reality someone gave me
a kid i need to sniff it like a smelling
sauce
tonight breaks its neck um well you know
what i want to get to a couple of
quick clips just so you guys have some
context okay here's the lie too
jen sackey tried to say that this is
actually uh
he's done 40 q a's he's done 40 press
conferences
q a since the beginning of his
presidency here's the clip that's a lie
follow up on a different subject um you
mentioned last week that the president
is expected to give a formal press
briefing um
the press conference yes before the end
of the month
so you so that is a commitment before in
the next few weeks we
will see him and give him take questions
and follow-ups and so forth
yeah he he has done about about 40 q a's
since he took office but in terms of a
formal press conference which i
understand there's a big
focus on yes we will have one before
because he's the president
now what she is including by the way is
every single
time joe biden has interacted with the
press including when he fell
on them so just to be clear this is how
they lie but the media just you saw that
report from the washington post reporter
telling people not to ask tough
questions you guys can in the control
room can bring that up i don't think we
have it prepared
um they're including interactions when
they say 40 q a's this
none there have been no press
conferences she is including
interactions
uh like this montage thank you mr
president for your confidence
thank you thank you um now we're gonna
get down to business here and uh
and uh ron who am i turn this over to
thank you very much mr president i think
it's time for the president our friends
in the press to leave them
thank you and that was a double whammy
because he was trying to say who am i
turning over and look for an
eight-year-old
why is he only wearing one mask thank
i see like a child who's proud that he
jumped off the high dive did you see me
i used the gift of sight
come on i'm such a loser after all it's
not one of those mall stores it looks
like it's ran by terrorists
thank you thank you thank you for the
purple suit story yes
i'm excited to take questions or classy
with two
eyes oh yeah and a glitter dress
yeah so so even the examples that they
use they don't trust him that was
riveting uh
at all and then we got two is the thing
that you guys just added really quickly
so
the pr team because we're running a
little late today and like i said we
will have a long post show so we're
playing the drinking game the promo code
is dementia not implying anything
crowder bidenstream if you watch this on
social we'll try and just sort of dip in
and out because we know that you want to
watch this and this is the only way to
make it palatable but we also want to
provide some insight
and then live fact checking afterward um
biden's pr team this is overlay d
they uh released an article at cnn
that's also just
think about that biden's pr team at cnn
releasing
okay okay saying that biden has been
getting ready for days to face the white
house press corps
as he has before in other major public
appearances nope biden has taken home
briefings but
uh home briefing books containing policy
questions and framing for potential
answers bidens three ring binders or
typically or
by the way uh romney's were full of
women yeah binding three-ring binders
are typically organized by topic with
tabs separating
anyway the whole point is they're trying
to say he's prepared and actually i
wanted to hit this before because it's a
nice
trafficking yes we just want to point
that out we have an exclusive actually
ladder with crowder
exclusive footage of his preparation for
these
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i i had not seen that
[Laughter]
really quick to before you move on you
might wonder why uh dave lionel looks
like he's put on a couple lbs like a fat
pride model
it's actually uh spartan armor is a
wonderful sponsor of the show where we
carry their
their uh uh their bulletproof vests and
they're also staff by the way some of
you people are saying you need the
coding on it so the fragments don't they
actually do have that you can go to
spartanarmorsystems.com don't stab them
yet hold on
hold on when you get to get the long
shot oh i didn't even notice
can't get the long shot all right
brendan step it in stab dave show them
that it's a real knife
cut yourself no well i wouldn't it is a
real
knife it's real stab dave give it a
little more juice give us some power
how you doing dave i'm good all right
good rehearsal made my uh
my jacket red spartan armor systems.com
uh you get 10 off using the coupon code
crowder
and just to be uh clear too they're also
nij certified a lot of other places say
like they're nij equivalent yeah which
means
nothing no yeah most of the jokes like
helps your posture and it's comfy yeah
it's comfortable that's because we fit
in a scoliosis rack
oh thank you we're used to wearing this
from detroit anyway
yes that's right i tend to go this is
how i go grocery shopping
if i go to live taste dave and then
especially we can't joke about grocery
stores anymore
no that's true i'm sorry son of a [ __ ]
i don't want to get fight a lot i've got
a lawsuit with facebook who's in detroit
what is that what else
twitter youtube and now publix no
there's no public scenario
in hell dave landon no no
there's kroger oh yeah yes there's
kroger
super foods and keep in mind too with
what do you expect tonight and i know i
know you're more
you know you just want to hit joe but
what do you really expect of biden i
think he'll [ __ ] his pants
yeah we may not know it but i think he's
going to be wearing at least two masks
and two diapers
you have to watch for the facial
expressions yeah yeah he definitely is
gonna
like he'll at least shart yeah to the
point that he'll be thinking about it
yeah
he'll be like does that go did that go
all the way yeah it'll be at the front
of his mind and he i expect him to sort
of always he always tries to act
flippant
when he has no leg to stand on you know
oh come on look
this is you know what we're going to do
okay we can't we got to be careful
okay look come on come on people say
that please
that's what he's going to do yeah you're
going to try and act as though uh there
hasn't there haven't been
mass shootings uh that there isn't a
migrant border crisis
surge right and a lot of people might be
asking look why is he
uh so well oh oh wait did we already do
this the uh montage a
yeah yeah yeah we did okay here's
something else that i wanted to say
before we get he's already running late
by the way two minutes later
that's a shock it's supposed to be at 12
15.
so he hasn't done any press conferences
this is unheard of for a president
nothing even close to one by the way no
nothing even close not a legit q a
the time where he even thought he's like
that did you ever see the last emperor
yes
syrian candidate uh with peter o'toole
where when he wants to actually take
some actions as emperor they're like no
that's him he's like oh i'll take some
questions and they just usher them out
and put them in the stocks
that's pretty much what's been happening
like he thinks that he can do more
than they know he can't yeah and so why
do we think he's been so reclusive and
not actually been communicating directly
with the people
maybe because of the interactions that
he has had uh
in the past they've been like this
i think that's a montage b
no you think i'm kidding it's almost not
there now but anyway
his leg goes floppy there which worries
me honestly no joke it seems like it
could be a stroke or a broken ankle
now when president harris and i took a
virtual tour of a vaccination center in
arizona
not long ago a lot of people don't know
how to register not everybody in the
community
in the hispanic and the african-american
community particularly in
rural areas that are distant and or
inner city
districts know how to use know how to
get online
like he's still figuring it out by the
way he was talking about
i love what he said uh african-americans
and hispanics and then just tried to
cover his aspect in uh
rural communities wi-fi yeah
he had to come back and he's like and in
domestic
interest come on man they don't they
don't urban
they don't the thing they don't all have
iphones some of them they're still using
sidekicks
your name's cardi b people call me joby
we could be related yeah i like your
talk if you're
going down on things and you know and
you know the thing is uh
it was disturbing for a long time
because uh you know i spent hours today
you know i'm not sure i couldn't find
cartier i couldn't there's no cartier
there's cardio the doctor says if i do
it i will certainly perish
[Laughter]
he's the kind of guy you can't leave the
bug zapper on the porch because he's
gonna find him there the next day
stuck he feels like it would he'd just
be a grandparent calling from florida
right and then you would hang up and go
he's not doing well
[Laughter]
we need to go visit honey he doesn't
have much time probably wouldn't even
have to respond it'd be like your wife
goes
hey how's how's grandpapp doing and you
would just look
yeah really no how many push-ups you
want to do here pal
[Laughter]
well i'm interested to see what he does
when he comes out right when you do
these press conferences you try to lead
off breaking news
yeah and kind of control the trajectory
of the questions and everything else and
i i wonder if it's going to be we're
going up to 200 million vaccines instead
of 100 million and because we'd already
almost gotten that from the previous guy
i mean he might actually say something
like that on accident
and we have one ready i think we'll
probably have to show it after uh the
press conference because um
gosh for crying out loud it's 20 it's
he's five minutes late
he's five minutes late he's still not
there that by the way
is perfectly analogous to uh uh uh joe
biden's presidency it's like the cr
the empty crutch by a fire with tiny tim
well they're probably just making sure
he says the right thing like when they
bring up 200 million shots they're like
so we're not talking about chicago
right right now he's right now the
problem is they're having to they're
having to talk him down because he's
really concerned about the speak and
spell
he's talking to me it knows my name
they're showing him the judge reinhold
fred savage scene from vice versa
to explain how he's got to answer the
questions he's
repeat them when they come into your ear
right now salute the marines
right now he's looking in the oval
office closet door for howie mandel
he's lost trying to find it where's the
power glove
um what it looks we have the montage
after this
uh to compare the energy of donald
trump's
uh press conferences versus what we will
see from joe biden
also to see how the media um would jump
on him look
i always say you have to go into it with
eyes wide open and so when conservatives
would just complain about the media
being biased i always appreciated that
uh donald trump
knew it and he went on the attack ron
desantis is probably the only other
person who i can think of who does it as
effectively
and conversely joe biden knows that he
has a friendly audience with the media
he knows they're not going to they're
not going to call him to the mat on the
vaccines they're not going to call him
to the mat on the
on on the border crisis right now and
what we need to keep in mind too with
the border crisis because it is a crisis
is they will say well look at how many
people
uh came to the border under trump yet
that's not the number that matters
the number that matters is how many
illegal immigrants
successfully made it to the border and
were released uh to the interior of the
united states i think i have that number
here
uh which page is it there gerald can you
tell me the uh the border stuff we're
talking page eight
page eight yeah cause this is something
i heard that they were saying uh in an
interview well actually uh
72 percent of these migrants are turned
away and i don't have
nails so i wish i wish i were a broad it
makes it tough oh i wish i had a vagina
but i guess i what i really don't get is
for four years we watched every single
reporter try to have a gotcha moment
right and that's why i'm wondering why
doesn't it happen now wouldn't at least
one person try
yeah oh okay here we go i got a couple
of numbers for you uh because this is a
border crisis right they went all
in on trump with kids and cages which
were pictures from barack obama so
uh biden broke the record for most
unaccompanied minors right in custody
3 200. okay so that's one that's
significant we have that from cnn yeah
um the total number of migrant children
in custody right now is over 16
000. only this is something i guess we
can show this clip really quickly since
he's probably
busy doing paperwork and by that wiping
he's stuck with single fly
double mask single ply i don't like and
they don't see the iron he's stuck in
the drapes back there
if it's a short clip she claimed that
the majority of immigrant families were
actually being
turned away the vast majority of people
who come to the border are turned away
uh adults families single uh
people who are coming to the border are
turned away right
so here's a number that i have for you
actually it's 13 of families are being
turned away what
only 25 illegal immigrants were given
humanitarian release into the united
states and into the interior in october
november and december and 2020 combined
do you know what it what it's been now
two months into biden's presidency so
this is the number that matters not how
many are at the border how many migrants
are
you know knocking to get in because if
we tell them not by the hair of my
chinny chin chin which also biden can't
grow despite being 95.
it doesn't matter it's irrelevant do you
know how many
have been released into the interior of
the united states just in 2021
how many uh 10 000. what 10
1 25 to 10
i say for every family that gets in we
send in a senator
yeah we just throw our trash back over
the fence
oh just people just like hey listen we
appreciate that you sent jorge and taco
and in exchange barney frank yeah please
enjoy his tits
the cartel's like no don't go we don't
want that
don't go be careful hey bonnie frank
gonna invite you in his basement
only he's not a basement he's lacking
above ground pool
only he does weird things he's not
beautiful in mexico so he showed up
he showed up now everybody's growing
this it's like it's contagious and
strange
that's a good thing
that's really or something we have fema
at the border
right now i expect him to talk about gun
control because and i expect him to take
credit by the way for the assault
weapons ban oh oh sure
why did the assault i did the assault
weapons ban we can do it again
which is an incredible thing to brag
about considering that it did nothing
right
yeah um as a matter of fact oh wait hold
on a second let's turn up the volume i
think it's going out
former vice president joe biden it is
crowder biden stream promo code is
dementia hold on he's gonna say that
he's not coming out let's bring up the
volume
does there need to be more of an effort
there to get church leaders community
leaders and others to to get the shot
and set a leadership role
absolutely absolutely i have these
conversations with people
everywhere did you see that and the way
they didn't cover what that guy just
said
tell me can anyone send me a message and
by the way will be taking your chat on
top mug club afterwards can does anyone
know what does anyone have the raw feed
what did he just say
cnn clearly didn't want him right over
it to set to
to so weird to be heard
he probably came out and said uh we
apologize joe biden pooped
we're trying to clean it up right now
it's the whole process i'm telling i
really do feel like this is a guy who's
being ushered from room to room who has
no idea what's going on
yeah yeah genuinely yeah genuinely i i
you know what here's what's so sad about
joe biden is he doesn't have anyone in
his life who cares about him his kids
while they're
doing crack off their nieces hip bones
are just using him for their deals their
money you appreciate that there's no
question
you know it can't be done off the breast
which common misconception you need if
you need a firm surface i think he burns
them with the crack pipe like rick james
yes
or the founder of kwanzaa what was his
name his name was like something like
fred willard
and then he changed it to like and it
was just like no you just burned it
with a soldering iron crack pipes
no that's not his real name that's a
[ __ ] crap oh sorry ronald mckinley
what is his name ron ronald mckinley
everett it's a lot different
ron mckinley everett yeah ron everett
ron everett sounds like a scientologist
he does he's the founder of kwanzaa
so yes but his family his fam
his family he's surrounded by by clint
you know his wife is
his wife's a climber yeah and his kids
couldn't care less because they just
want to get some deals that they've
never actually earned themselves
and so no one is saying look dan you
know what this this isn't this isn't
good
they're not taking care of the guy and
you know i will say this former vice
president joe biden
i don't agree with him on much he
doesn't know what he believes truth be
told
if you were to tell him about the whole
trans and sports thing 10 years ago
he probably would have laughed you out
of the room he probably would have said
that it's a straw man a slippery slope
intellectual fallacy
and that's what so said he doesn't know
what he believes he figures this is one
of the
one of the boxes that he wanted to tick
and so he's finally oh okay all right
here he comes
here comes the former vice president in
which we covered his gaffes well never
mind here he is let's listen to him the
46th president of the united states
joseph robinette biden i want to give
you a progress report
to the nation on uh
on where we stand 65 days into office
here
on vaccinations and a few other top
priorities for the american people
first on vaccinations on december 8th
i indicated that i hope to get 100
million
shots in people's arms in my first 100
days
drank that goal last night
42 days ahead of schedule now today i'm
setting the second goal
and that is we will by my 100th day in
office
have administered 200 million shots
in people's arms that's right 200
million shots in
100 days i know it's ambitious
twice our original goal but no other
country in the world has even come
close not even close to what we were
doing
so that's dangerously close to
nationalism they're dead today
we made a historic investment in
reaching the hardest hit
and the most vulnerable communities the
highest risk communities
as a consequence of the virus breaking
rules by investing in additional people
10 years younger than you and being able
to reach them high risk i also set a
goal before i
took office of getting a majority of
schools
in k through 8 fully open
in the first 100 days now thanks to the
enormous amount of work done by
our administration educators parents
local state education officials and
leaders
recent department of education survey
shows that do you mean that
you didn't want to go back to work k
through 8 schools are open now full-time
five days a week for in-person learning
not yet a majority
but we're really close and i believe in
the 35 days left to go we'll meet that
goal as well yeah because you made sure
that no schools were allowed
but now you're like
have gone into people's bank accounts
that's real money
in people's pockets bringing relief
instantly
it's been coming out of our pockets yeah
and millions more will be getting their
money
it's our money yeah thanks for giving a
final note
by the way he does he's not allowed to
have pockets they sew them shut just in
case he loses his meds
to see new signs constantly looking for
his werther's originals
since it was passed a majority
a majority of economic forecasters
have significantly increased their
projections
on the economic growth that's going to
take place this year
they're now projecting it will exceed
six percent a six percent growth in gdp
just this morning no of course not of
course yeah when you try to shut down
the economy to win an election yeah
and then you say okay you can uh open
back up now
because herd immunity is one hell of a
thing i guess you can take credit it's
the first time
also six percent growth after crippling
everything isn't really impressive it's
like six percent yeah
that's very little so there are still
too many americans out of work
too many families they still have a lot
of work to do
but i can say to you the american people
help is here and hope is on the way
could you imagine joe biden he was your
paramedic
hey question relax help is here you like
get away yeah
don't worry there's no associated
problems am i going to die
huh shut up man thank you mr president
you mentioned your progress on kobe 19
i'd like to ask you about some of the
other issues
chasing your presidency one of the
defining challenges you face in the
coming months
is how to deliver on your promise to
americans on issues like immigration
reform
gun control voting rights climate change
all of those right now are facing stiff
united opposition from republicans on
capitol hill
how far are you willing to go to achieve
those promises that you made to the
american
it was a fairly basic simple proposition
oh good and that is i got elected to
solve
problems and the most urgent problem
facing the american people i stated from
the outset
was coveted 19 and the economic
displacement
[Laughter]
very complicated for my foot doctor from
immigration you mean podiatrist you're a
pediatrician
why are you here i want a sticker
long-term problems they've been around a
long time i got a ball and it hits one
ball
bounces and does it for hours is
or guns or a number of other problems
that face the country
but the fundamental problem guns are not
a problem
the immigration is you some peace of
mind
so they can go to bed at night and not
stare at the ceiling wondering whether
they lost their health insurance
better not staring at them
that softball question seemed like it
was kind of fed to him because
when we were doing research before the
show um the cnn article
it was so vague from the state of
bipartisanship to the future
like this is one of the things that they
were saying would come up that's all the
guys said yeah
yeah it's totally fed to them to
determine whether or not
we want to work together or their decide
that the way in which
they want to proceed is to uh is to uh
just a vein coming in divide the country
never going to continue
it's all about unity yeah so let's work
together
if you can't make progress on those four
challenges climate change immigration
reform gun control
voting rights well i plan on making
progress on all of them but
you mean making progress like what is
gas gas prices are up
38 40 huge the last time they were this
high was under barack obama it's no it's
not the texas freeze because i was in
arizona recently it's over five dollars
in california
he's made some progress because he's
already made the the oil market is
largely determined and it's
unpredictable
but by speculators of course and they
know that this guy is a guy who will
make uh
make access to our own reserves much
more difficult so gas prices have gone
up
immediately keystone immediately uh
immigration
immediately record numbers of people
being released so you know what from
syria
syria okay how about
yamiche guys just so he's got a list
he's trying to not listen to the
president he said over and over again
that immigrants shouldn't come to this
country right now this isn't the time to
come
that message is not being received
instead the perception of you
that got you elected as a moral decent
man is
oh my god this is the president but god
elected the elected you're the moral
decent man
really resolved real attention this is a
guy who had to
who had to exit the 19th was it 1988
presidential race
in disgrace yep and is there a time
racial jungle
we won't be seeing these overcrowded
facilities with run by cpb
when it comes to unaccompanied minors
well look i guess i should be flattered
people are coming because i'm the nice
guy that's the reason why it's happening
what
yeah only you don't have to deal with it
it's the american
public who has to deal with it not only
in the form of
job loss not only in the form of of of
of obviously uh feeling as though their
states are no longer secure
but they're actually getting attacked if
you look at the likelihood of an illegal
immigrant that's a stat they always
throw out oh legal immigrants cause
crime
commit fewer crimes of course it's their
legal immigrants because they're on the
books that can be deported
illegal immigrants commit crime at a
much much higher rate 10
000 in the year of 2021 released to the
interior of the united states it's not
because you're a nice guy
it's because you're a [ __ ]
of january february march
that happens every year in addition to
that
there is a and nobody and by the way
does anybody see so the surge is
seasonal 31
increase under trump because he
hey it's like a farm to table menu with
the thing that's not the reason
do they still make surge
[ __ ] increase under trump can we
fact check that there's 332
under under donald trump if he means
there was a 31 increase at one point in
time of people
trying to get to the border sure there
was not a 31 increase in people released
in the united states
the number that matters is people that's
why a wall is important people try to
come to the country
are they turned away or are they granted
access until their court date
again the number that we have 25
released in the united states in october
november december of 2020
10 000 in 2021 i'm not sure what
percentages
are for that but it's got to be more
than 37 gotta be more dismantle
all the elements that exist to deal with
what had been a problem
and what and has been continued to be a
problem for a long time well the
president of mexico
shut down the uh the number of beds
available
he did not fund hhs to get people to get
the children out of those those border
patrol facilities where they should not
be and not supposed to be more than by
the way this is why
this is why there's a record just to be
clear this is the problem that they
create
when they say they didn't get the beds
and because the point is
we shouldn't have policies that
encourage unaccompanied minors by the
way
sex trafficking used to matter to people
that's why we have a record number of
unaccompanied minors we have
3 200 in 2019 compared to 2 600 under
trump and that was a big year last year
why because now they're going oh wait a
second oh wait a second if the kids
just don't have an adult then they can
go and then they can send this green
card okay
by jorge that's what happens they're
sending on do you have any idea how
dangerous that is
you give you creating more hotel rooms
for unaccompanied miners giving them
space blankets and dehydrated ice cream
is not fixing the problem it's just
encouraging
families to send more children without
any kind of adults to the border yeah
that's horrible the families that are
coming
out now with mexico their willingness to
take
more of those families back but we
that that's what's happening they're not
getting across the border and those who
are coming across the border as they are
so i would argue is his cab moving
rapidly to try to put
vice president cabinet that was
separating the children
from the parents which then led to this
that's why he's using more cages has to
get his money's worth right
16 or 17 years old we're not talking
about people ripping babies from
mother's arms or little three-year-olds
standing on the border
less than i think it's one and a half
percent fall in the category of the very
young
so what we're doing very providing space
again to be able to play cambrian
he may have sniffed very young just
before he walked out he knows it very
well
smells very young
i went to for example i used all the
resources available to me
went to the defense department and and
the secretary of defense has just made
available fort bliss
5 000 beds do you think he has to wind
his teeth
before he talks 5 000 beds in the texas
you think if you throw him off a
high-story building he has a little
pouch that goes
[Laughter]
yes you wouldn't hit a guy with glasses
would you uh i would it's gonna take
figuratively by the way do you see
something do you notice a trend
do you notice a trend he's talking about
giving stuff to people who are trying to
get into this country illegally he's not
talking about policies that'll actually
stop the flow of illegal immigration
which is bad for who
who's it's bad for americans
natural-born americans it's bad for
legal immigrants and it's bad for the
illegal immigrants themselves because
then they can be abused then they can
effectively be indentured
servants right when it comes well they
are
oh hold on she's asking there's
immigration is a big issue of course
with when it relates but there's also
republicans who are passing bill after
bill
trying to restrict voting rights chuck
schumer is calling it
an exercise a threat to democracy why
not back
a filibuster rule that at least gets
listen if you guys are drinking at the
leading
questions we're gonna die switch to uh
water switch to natty light
you know very well um has that the idea
of a filibuster rule
when it comes to civil rights and voting
rights don't conflate that too
don't conflate that to civil rights and
voting rights look
civil we're talking about people not
having the right to vote that's very
different from saying hey
we just want to make sure that we know
who you are voting
you have an id it's what they are let me
go through this where's the the
okay here's what they want here's what
their bill is really quickly so i'm
i'm really pissed at this [ __ ] okay
their bill
hr one and by the way liable to confuse
hr127 is the
crazy absolute bat [ __ ] crazy gun bill
this is hr1 we have all the sources
available at ladder credit.com by the
way
allows same day and automatic
registration expands early voting
prohibits
voter id prohibits signature requirement
mandates no excuse absentee voting one
absentee ballot application for
all future elections what could go wrong
there uh forces states to accept
mail-ins up to 10 days after the
election day allow
16-year-olds to register to vote or as
joe biden refers to them his romantic
interests
mandates districts redrawn by unelected
bureaucrats
limits the ability to clean up voter
rolls and makes dc estate
what do republicans want voter id and if
you're voting mail-in that you have a
reason for it
that's about it you want to if you're
saying that's racist
you're a racist literally weeks and
weeks and maybe even months before
anybody pick up the phone and call
to see if they're really working yes
well
we've set up a system now where within
24 hours there's a phone call made
as that person that child crosses the
border
and then a verification system being put
in place as
as of today to determine quickly whether
or not
that is a trafficker being called or
that is actually
a mom a dad and or a close relative
they're establishing that right off the
bat if it in fact
is mom or dad dad says to take the
extreme case i got a birth certificate
then guess what we're getting that kid
you know what this is this is
complicating a problem
we have a child and he's not answering
the voting rights by the way a
trafficker can never pretend to be a dad
right
it's like hey hey is this uh is this
pico's father
he flips through the script uh yes yes
good enough for me
by the way your son smells lovely click
yeah here's the issue here
yeah kim's never said i'm her dad if
they're actually being sent by parents
yeah
across the border health and human
services they can be sent back to their
parents
yeah you don't need to have some caller
id and a mission impossible voice
recognition software it's
oh well your mom and dad have some
splaining to do
why don't you take yourself right on
back and that will discourage
parents from being shitty guardians and
sending kids across the border
i'm sorry it is not empathy when you
remove
law and order from the books it enables
cruelty it always
does let's listen to this guy because i
just i'm sorry i don't want you to get
caught up in the velocity
i don't know none of this is aimed at
why i have this vest it's very nice they
told me it was for knives and if you
went a little mad yeah
it used to be required for the
filibuster and i i had a card
horizontal like monte cristo on the wall
that
it used to be that uh that was
from between 1917 and 1971 the
filibuster existed do it there are a
total of
58 motions to break a filibuster
by the way hey have the team bring this
up afterwards um
keep in mind that they tried to ram i
don't remember if it was the public
option or obamacare through with
filibuster
okay taking over a fifth of the economy
with filibuster i don't remember if
that's what they did or they just did
something
oh that's right they tried to use it
through reconciliation well then there
were two because there was a filibuster
that there was sorry there was a
filibuster but there was something there
was some other you're right yeah i
reckon there was something else though
that they did something with something
with obamacare it could have been an
addendum to it or an earmark i don't
remember exactly there was a filibuster
the point is they used it like
crazy they used it like crazy when
they've had control
what i like about the obamacare is how
all my liberal friends were furious they
had to pay for the insurance
yeah and now they're championing this
guy and getting mad at me where it's
like didn't you scream at me
for a while my whole thing was i thought
the
uh pre-existing conditions may have gone
a little too far
because i have the you know that i think
the insurance companies were screwing
people over for that
they were just angry that they had to
pay 60 dollars that's
fine oh i'm surprised it was that low
well it depends where you were at
so that the vice president
51 votes without her and so
i'm going to say something outrageous i
have never been particularly poor at
calculating how to get things done
in the united states senate what so the
best way to get something done
i mean if you don't look at my track
record i've been pretty good anyway
oh he couldn't finish this anyway drink
drink he's getting tired and if we have
to if there's complete
lockdown and chaos as a consequence of
the filibuster then
we'll have to go beyond what i'm talking
about
what are you talking are you talking
about um
hang on uh
lost his train of thought by the way
getting rid of the philippines wow yeah
that's a good point
look little kim did he just call local
hello
thank you mr president um to follow up
on being abused in a gigantic way
don't you love how everyone has been a
minority on the legislation
well they have to what was the question
with 51. we were talking about ending
the filibuster still you're going to
have to
the existing rule uh it's going to be
hard to
get a parliamentary ruling that allows
50 votes to end the filibuster the
existence of a filibuster
um but um
it's possible the expertise and what the
parliamentary rules on how to get there
are but you've been in the senate
forever
your expertise is claiming credit for
bills where you didn't even vote
and now we're talking about what we're
going to do about the filibuster and the
what uh-huh did he just lose his trip he
lost it again that's three times in a
row
drank filibuster especially by the way
i'm gonna die the filibuster is there to
make sure somebody can't just
ram through their own policies against
the will of the american people it is
there to make sure on controversial
issues you have to get
60 votes listed the reasons that people
are coming uh
talking about in-country problems saying
that it happens every year
you blame the last administration sir i
just got back
last night from a recording trip to the
border where i met
nine-year-old jose who walked here from
honduras
along with another little boy he had
that on him
and we were able to call his family his
mother
says that she sent her son to this
country because she believes
that you are not deporting unaccompanied
that's why she sent him a loan from
honduras so
sir you blamed the last administration
but is your messaging and saying that
these children are
and will be allowed to stay in this
country and work their way through this
process
encouraging families like jose's to come
first decent question yes yeah
the idea that wow wow
which i would never do unaccompanied
can you put down the crack pipe for long
enough to help your dad get your daddy
good piece of [ __ ]
seriously i feel bad for the guy i
really do except trump
i'm not gonna do it i'm not gonna do it
that's why i've asked the vice president
united states yesterday
to be the lead person on dealing with
focusing on the fundamental reasons why
people leave honduras guatemala and el
salvador in the first place because
they're [ __ ] countries it's because
of
earthquakes floods
yeah people are leaving el salvador if
i'm not mistaken it's el salvador has
the highest murder rate in the world
not industrialized world because that's
a lofty goal for them it's
in the world period and i think honduras
is right up there yeah mexico is pretty
high i think mexico city might be the
worst
city but i'm pretty sure it's el
salvador is the country with the highest
murder rate
and uh they have 401k kidnapping over
there
and you believe it's because people get
a little dewy
it's the floods okay yeah i tend to walk
a couple of thousand miles because of
the flood too yeah yeah
well they've wanted to see a white
christmas that's why they come to the
u.s
tired of it being so high also i want to
come here to see your statue of liberty
to
meet your being crosby and also to not
be
raped for days on end without mercy
instead of us going down and helping i
hear you let the prisoners out for some
reason
because they have a cold they have to
come out really
sustenance el salvador wow sometimes i
amaze myself in our administration we're
going to be spending that just english
for the salvador's here
just so you know the life and
circumstances of why people leave in the
first place
people will be confused the other worst
country ever
on the kitchen table oh you're looking
for salvador biggie
yeah uh there's no more we killed him
we are now el only salvador
yeah would you by the way why would you
let a nine-year-old walk through
honduras
on top of it what a crafty nine-year-old
i mean maybe we could use him in the
states
get all the way here by himself send
over again uh
so we can do something about that that's
the vice president's going to be doing
what i did when president obama asked me
to come and deal
i was in i was in uh turkey at the time
he said you got to come home and take
care of this
so we put together a plan it had an
impact
and so the question here is whether how
we go ahead and do this what we do
there's no easy answer no specifics by
the way
none nothing follows if i may comment
want to see these unaccompanied minors
staying in this ch this country or
should they be deported eventually
well the judgment has to be made whether
or not and in this young man's case he
has a mom at home
there's a overwhelming reason why he'd
be putting a plane and flown back to his
mom
cancel free travel huh follow sir
you mentioned uh circles because you
have spirit points
customs and border protection facility
in donna texas i was there
is that 1556 capacity
right now with mostly unaccompanied
minors there are kids that are sleeping
on floors
they are packed into these pods i've
spoken to lawyers who say that
why don't you just put them in all the
hospitals they already have kobe and
those are empty right now
none of
cartels to snake island that's why it's
an egg per square meter
of those kids nightmares that's why
what's quickly being opened up that's
why i've been working from the moment
this started to happen to try to find
additional access
for children to be able to safely not
just children but particularly children
to be able to safely be housed while we
follow through on the rest of what's
happening
that is totally unacceptable the
the most humane thing to do would be put
them on a bus or a plane immediately
back
like the revolving door and elf they
shouldn't be sitting there for more than
half a day yeah it should be oh no
you're not this sorry you're not a
citizen by
all of troops from that country
as a candidate in foreign affairs you
wrote
that it is past time to end these
forever wars
can you commit to the american people
that by may 2nd
the u.s will no longer have forces
in afghanistan no the answer is that
didn't he bomb syria within like two
days
remember there was that peace in the
middle east thing yeah
remind me remind me write it down i have
a story about an iraqi uh cab driver
uh uber driver okay on the way back from
the airport it's a shocking statistic as
to how many middle eastern
uh american uh middle whatever people
from iraq and the united states support
donald
trump and because of the peace that they
had for four years
every uber driver i had in new york was
probably middle eastern and
many were from iraq and told me that
yeah and they're
really fired about what's going on all
of them yes and i said with our allies
and partners
and how to proceed and secretary blinken
as
meeting in brussels this week with our
nato
allies you just say able to particularly
those who have forces there
and general austin is just met with
kyani and i'm waiting for the briefing
on that he is the
the uh
call my nerves there's a un-led process
that's beginning
uh shortly on how to mechanically
get people how to end this war but it is
not my intention
to stay there for a long time but the
question is
how and in what circumstances do we meet
that agreement
that was made by president
trump to leave under a deal that looks
like it's not being able to be worked
out to begin with
how how's that done but we are not
staying
a long time by the way how was it three
peace deals with israel
under donald trump yeah three how many
deals are impressive
assault weapons deal you've done no
deals
yeah you don't even know how to coupon
shop for a deal i guarantee you by the
way if donald trump was still
president they would be out by may 2nd
he sets those deadlines and says
we're gone well you you forgot biden did
the deal between pfizer and merc
right yeah that's true that's true which
actually isn't true trump did that
but joe joe biden couldn't find a deal
if you gave him a shop and save a ten
percent off bed bath and beyond coupon
and a map
to allow he couldn't find a deal of big
lots and they got lots
full msrp for something you didn't even
want plan very shortly
is underway to let you have access 2021
f-150 with orlando roof
be able to have access to the facilities
we've obviously
been allowed to be inside one but we
haven't seen
the facilities in which children are
packed together
to really give the american people a
chance to see that will you commit to
transparency on this
i will commit to transparency and as
soon as i am in a position to be able to
implement what we're doing
right now right after we get the kids
out of there one of the reasons i
haven't gone down
i have always mine once it looks pretty
good i'll show you
look look the thing is we have one
you've been in the one room
the other secret service have you ever
seen blazing saddles
we're gonna the town it's a it's
cardboard
that's not real access to everything
once we get to
now access now to be clear that's
freedom of the press
i've noticed that the reporters that
appear to be uh possibly hispanic i want
to say possibly
seem a little bit more passionate than
the others
[Music]
did you move too quickly to roll back
some of the executive orders of your
presence ten thousand reasons as to why
yes
all the policies are underway we're
going to police the seas
did not slice immigration and there's
many people coming
and rolling back the policies of
separating
children from their from their mothers
to make no apology those were policies
under your
vice presidency mexico sitting on
the edge of the rio grande and a muddy
circumstance with not enough to eat
i make no apologies for that i make no
apologies for ending programs that did
not
get a reference to the john wayne moving
forward hey do you make uh do you make
any apologies to the
record number of women who've been raped
and people who've been killed on the
southern border in towns like el paso do
you make a pilot do you make apologies
to them
how about them i don't think he's gonna
apologize for his son so i make no
apologies for that
i want to ask you about foreign policy
mr president overnight
we learned that north korea did you see
that
cause she's asking follow-ups she's not
supposed to what if any actions will you
take and
what is your red line on north korea
so someone take that bitch's lanyard let
me say that uh
number one uh you weren't supposed to
resolution 1718 was violated by those
particular missiles that were tested
oh what are you going to do about it
we're consulting with our allies
and partners and
there will be uh responses if they
choose to escalate
like um we will respond accordingly
mm-hmm but i'm also prepared that's a
far cry from
fire and fury like they've never seen
everyone said that donald trump was too
cozy with kim jong-un yeah
because he actually crossed over that
border right into south uh into north
korea for the first time and met with
him
and he went there to make a deal and
when kim jong-un did not
meet the deal donald trump came back
called him little rocket man and said if
he does anything
he will be met with fire and fury like
he's never seen guess what no more tests
you have nothing and all of a sudden now
it's kind of popping back they're doing
tests
president trump she's asking north korea
was
the top i'd be more vocal i'm just so
scared
is that how you assess the crisis in
north korea yes
[Laughter]
by the way i think you just agreed with
trump yeah pretty much
that was not a one-word question oh no
you know we'll do some stuff and when we
do the stuff the stuff will happen it'll
happen yeah
i got it let me hear the questions guys
across the country
are working to pass bills that would
restrict voting particularly democrats
impacting minority people
of age elected in november
are you worried that if you don't manage
to pass
voting rights legislation that your
party is going to lose seats and
possibly lose control
of the house and the senate in 2022.
what i'm worried about is how unamerican
this whole initiative is well correct
it's sick
it's sick everyone hold on in some
states that you cannot
bring water to people standing in line
waiting to vote deciding that
you're going to end voting at five
o'clock when working people are just
getting off work deciding that
there will be no absentee ballots under
the most
rigid circumstances not true it's all
designed and i'm going to spend my time
doing three things
one trying to figure out how to pass
the legislation contracts number one
number two educating the american public
the republican voters i know
find this despicable republican voters
the folks out in the outside this white
house
i'm not talking about the the elected
officials
i'm talking about voters vote to vote
for the elected officials
and so i'm convinced that we'll be able
to stop this because
it is the most pernicious thing this
makes jim crow
look like jim eagle i mean this is
gigantic
what they're trying to do and it cannot
be that a reference to something that's
swinging into 20
of my power along with my friends in the
house in the senate
waiting from uh from becoming hit number
three
is there anything else what did i tell
you
call me nostradamus [ __ ] i told him he
had three things to remember
he forgot one and number two was all a
lie and a reference to i assume a
quarterback
to the age of when that had leather
hello i don't know an eagle is bigger
than a crow
oh jim eagle huh makes it look like jim
dodo bird
it's jim paterada johnny flamingo
huh flamingo kid you know matt dylan you
know what i'm talking about
wow joey blue jays you know they want 16
year old
let's let's do this math okay really
quickly before we go to this 10
000 people 10 000 people illegal
immigrants released into the united
states
right in 2021 10 000 people and they
want no voter id
and they want 16 he just said the
majority of them aren't three they're
16. well guess what
their bill 16 year olds registered to
vote
with no necessary identification do that
math how many states
border states were within ten that's
only in two months
in a year you know it'll be what 20 40
100 000
arizona nevada these were within 10 to
20 000 votes
yeah it was very close all of them under
the name
jim eagle yeah we should have seen it
i could only beat so many gym eagles
i would expect such a big [ __ ] but this
might be the dumbest thing i've ever
seen the lid gets blown off because
one like no why'd you why'd you write
bob hawk i don't know
we all agreed he's one bird of prey but
i got the hawkeye
oh no you don't you have glaucoma hey
what about a falcon
don't stop with your [ __ ] [ __ ] again
but i train them
and so doing just [ __ ] helmets did
you write the jacob a peacock
so far left well then you ought to take
a look at his party
over 50 percent of them must be over
that edge as well
because they support what i did uh
right now he's holding up the size of
jim eagle's package yeah where am i here
i plan to be alive in 2024 yes that is
correct
that's the plan yeah thank you very much
i've been working on
stairs for you but first i'd like to
follow up on a question from yamiche
and that's on the phone that counts as a
question but go ahead okay i'll make it
quick
no no you can't let me smell your hair
i'll let you go guarding the filibuster
at john lewis's funeral president barack
obama said he believed the filibuster
was a relic
of the jim crow era do you agree yes
if not why not abolish it if it's a
relic of the jim crow era
did you hear my joke about jim eagle
i referenced that successful electoral
politics is the art of the possible
let's figure out how we can get this
done
and move in the direction now come over
here you jacketed flamenco
verbal essence is beautiful [ __ ] i like
that those buttons are placed on your
nips
reminds me of party frank an extreme way
in the we sent him to el salvador i
haven't seen him in a while
pink on the outside prank on these oh
eliminating the filibuster is that
correct
i'm doing it as him yeah yeah i can
answer your question what
you also just made some news by saying
that you are going to run for
re-election
i said that is my expectation could be
this is that a yes
running for re-election look i i don't
know where you guys come from man i've
never been able to travel i'm a great
perspective i've never been able to plan
four and a half three and a half years
ahead for certain oh and you're ready to
go whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
yeah and he basically told her i can't
answer this question because there's
such a thing as actuary tables
right i can't be expected to plan ahead
come
on i'm the president yeah oh come on why
would a president run for two terms
that's great it'll be a republican party
do you
i know you don't have to answer my
question but are you getting spicy with
me uh
turtle shell nipple girl the way i view
things i become a great respecter of
fate in my life
i set a goal of this in front of me to
get things done
for the people i care most about which
are hard hard-working decent
american people are getting really
having it stuck to them
yeah stuck to them by wages being driven
down through illegal immigration
stuck to them by having their businesses
shut down and not being able to work
stuck to them by not being able to put
their kids back into school stuck to
them because they have a horrible
economy they have an immigration problem
like they've never seen and by the way
you want to take their guns away and you
don't give any press conferences because
you don't see the american people fit
to uh communicate with you so and being
attacked on the street because you've
convinced them if they don't wear a face
garb
that they're somehow killing you right
do you hear them complain
when they passed close to two trillion
dollar trump tax cut
83 percent going to the top one percent
that helped the economy
by the way it didn't it didn't go to the
top one yeah again that's just you're
just talking about total numbers
vast majority just to be clear we have
this too someone can bring it up
the vast majority of people under donald
trump with those tax cuts pay less
yeah now look if you're here's the thing
if you make a billion dollars and you're
paying slightly less of a percentage of
a billion dollars telling me but you're
making
americans 70 000 and you're paying
you're still both paying less in taxes
this is the problem with the left it's
not that it's dishonest although that
is also a problem it's that it preys on
humanity's
worst vices and evils jealousy greed
fat pride gluttony right on unearned
unearned uh accolades and awards illegal
immigration
this is the or maternity flight suits or
lowering pt standards at uh at uh
to join our armed forces i just had a
biden moment right there the issue here
is let's continue with what he's i'm
sorry i've been talking for too long
dignity honor honesty
transparency to the american political
system
two how about letting them see the first
backbone of this country
once they get them middle class
hard-working people and people
struggling
in the middle class they built america
and unions built them [ __ ] no
[ __ ] [ __ ] you hey how about this
this is
that's that's a regurgitation of the guy
who you know obviously he
he does his cup check for him barack
obama and he said you didn't build that
again he's pandering to people who think
oh
i can't do anything without a union by
the way who are who
99 if i'm a member of the seiu or
electrical union or teachers union
99 of our donations go to democrats i
can't do anything without a union
what about the small business owners
what about the right to work stage which
by the way is an increasing trend
you want just like barack obama told
business owners
you didn't build that because through
your tax dollars we
incredibly efficiently might i add built
roads for you so
technically you should thank the
government and right now he's saying
technically you can't make it on your
own
it's not your own merit at least not the
system that i want in place so thank a
union
average americans the average american
saw a salary increase an increase of
earnings the
average wage went up by 5 000
in three years we can factor that bring
it up later on under donald trump
under eight years of obama 1 000. and he
started with a
terrible he started down of course and
just
had nowhere to go but up and only got a
thousand appropriate
he cares about everyone but the american
middle class who aren't beholden to
unions
he cares about illegal immigrants he
cares about voting bases
uh and purchasing votes he cares about
union money he cares about big banks so
he wants to lock out people trading game
stop
he doesn't care about the average
american he doesn't he couldn't care
less he wants to cut your wages you've
seen the growth under donald trump he
wants to increase your taxes
and he wants to make sure that you have
to compete for jobs in a labor pool
with unskilled uh immigrants who didn't
even have to sign the guest book oh and
by the way they can vote as young as 16.
looking out for you when he can finish a
sentence sorry let me hear this double
mascot [ __ ]
uh international payment systems oh look
uh
[Music]
it's the best you could look today sir
legitimate questions but the only
i couldn't hear them through the two
masks and pube beard yeah a
smidgen of what the relationship with
china really is about
i've known xi jinping for a long time
allegedly by the time i left office as
vice president i had spent more time
with xi jinping than any world leader
had because
president obama and the chinese
president who
decided we should get to know one
another and he's on first it's
inappropriate
for the president united states to spend
time with the vice president of another
country
but it was obvious he was going to
become the new leader of china
and how that worked out for the american
worker
how did that work out for the american
worker with that cozy relationship with
taina on the trans-pacific partnership
worked out well for him got some good
business deals out yeah of course yeah
straightforward i mean hunter biden i'm
a hunt hunter well yes
he's more of an opium guy yes smart guy
he's one of the guys fairness is for his
legs that break when he walks upstairs
no no one talked about a stutter these
are inabilities to find his thoughts as
well as mine
listening we had a two hour the problem
with everything since it becomes corrupt
even the same with unions and that's the
sad thing i think that they started in a
very
a very noble thing right and the
industrial revolution where this was you
know we went from library in society to
now we did have classes and they said
okay we need to make sure that people
aren't working seven days a week
and a factory where they lose an arm on
a conveyor belt oh yeah well they're
like your kid who's
[ __ ] sorry this was 12. you're
filling a meat grinder
right what are you saying yeah yeah
here you go why does this have a young
man's nail in it it's fine eat it
but then jimmy hoffa was like hey let's
loan all this money
i don't know where he is this is to you
in order to compete effectively i
indicated that my
step grandfather who was mayor of
bloomfield township saw him
at the uh whatever it was the fox
whatever yeah the restaurant is still
there he was there that day
really yeah when he saw jimmy office oh
wow sorry let's go
i think he was incinerated in into metal
for cars that's what he's doing in fort
knox
do you think guys stop getting off track
we have to listen to uh
former vice president sorry i got bored
you know
back in the 60s we used to invest a
little over two percent of our entire
entire gdp in pure research
and investment in science today it's 0.7
percent
i'm going to change that we're going to
change that
the future lies and who can in fact
own the future as it relates to
technology quantum computing a whole
range of things
including the medical fields and so
what i'm going to do is make sure we
invest what was that
one of the reasons why the major just
attacked a small
child on a tour yeah it just came back
the new ones even worse
is uh we're going to invest in medical
research
cancer alzheimer's diabetes the things
industries of the future artificial
intelligence quantum computing are we
looking into all the things i have
and we're going to make real investments
china is out investing us
by a long shot because their plan is to
own that future
it's because it's a communist government
where nothing is your own you dip
[ __ ] if you want to go from two point
whatever percent like you were saying
go back up to it because we're only at
point seven percent where are you going
to cut it yeah
it's like this idea of balancing a
budget doesn't occur to them that only
occurs to
sorry the middle class americans who
built this country who actually have to
do some quick books
i'm happy well they're just gonna get
rid of that though but
one of the things that i'm going to be
doing i'm going to be speaking with uh
20 so
yeah hold on one second by the way like
i said a stat proof it's also hatchet
proof
it's a real hatchet real deal okay there
you go
no no no it's still there
it is isn't it yeah all right dave are
you still that's enough that's enough
because i'm just worried about hand
fatigue and a mess
spartan armorsystems.com they're
actually nij certified use the promo
code
or you get 10 off you should everyone
should have them in their house at least
one
i feel like a ninja turtle yeah yeah
with the shell you're like
i really do like it's comfy i know it's
mine
it it you you can't even feel it you're
ready to fight just hitting me with an
axe with his bad hand
huh said you live in a sewer i do live
in a sewer draft
pizza a rat trains me
but it's for most their labels nij
certified by the way the ones that are
this one is
this one is they offer some less they
offer some less expensive options for
people who
maybe just want to get into the market
but don't because listen getting that
certification is expensive and it also
guarantees you quality all right let's
go back to uh mr white eye
taiwan or a whole range of other things
and the third thing hey i just heard him
mention taiwan are you talking about the
the the place that uh the world health
organization refuses to acknowledge even
exists
next question no pretense about not
understanding
i pointed out to him no leader can be
sustained in his position or her
position
unless they represent the values of the
country
and i said as and uh mr president as
i've told you before
americans value the notion of freedom
america values human rights we don't
always live up to our expectations but
it's a value system
eight years joe what'd you do it's
rhetoric it's just
what you do and your country continues
to so blatantly violate human rights
we are going to continue in an
unrelenting way to call to the attention
of the world
who is violating human rights making
clear what's happening but he's good
friends with them he understood
yeah he understood me but i wouldn't do
anything
but you signed agreements that sent
american jobs there
reduced our ability to compete and you
said that we should trust the world
health organization who was doing
china's bidding by the way
and uh we know what happened i can't say
it on youtube
i can't actually include the world
health organization screenshots from
what they were saying in january
so you know as the last one did
is the moment we began to lose our
legitimacy around the world
do you say momo to lose auto generously
yeah china china drink an overall goal
and china has a wall it's a great wall
pretty big
uh i understand the world
the wealthiest country in the world and
the most powerful country in the world
that's not going to happen on my watch
because united states might watch it
what do say did he just say the united
states is the wealthiest country in the
world the most powerful country in the
world and it's not going to happen
now that china wants to be that his
decision his watch is over hey
beard sanctions no that's not what makes
decisions that's where i make sure
good bam margera greasy i'm on opioids
hair
right because that is what is at stake
not just with china's right at home
that's something i can't chew anymore
we're in the midst of a fourth
industrial revolution
of enormous consequence will there be
middle class
how will people adjust to these
significant changes in science and
technology
the environment how will you do that
look look on our democracy you had your
well i mean i know you were you were a
patsy for the higher ups
eight years the middle class suffered
they paid more in taxes
they made less money they saw
skyrocketing health costs okay
that was and there were for two of those
years you had control of every single
chamber
all right let's make that clear then in
three years under trump until this
manufactured reaction to the pandemic
they had record wage growth record low
unemployment not only for middle class
americans but for every demographic race
and creed
you had eight years you can compare it
with three that's what i'm looking
forward to doing now is comparing
this uh next three years is being
generous but let's go with that for
right now because i don't want to be
removed
to the previous administration mr
president sorry
i know you have another chance to
address uh the tragedies in georgia and
colorado uh you had said to stay tuned
for actions that you might take
on gun control wondering if you've made
a decision
either about sending the manufacturer
liability bill that you promised on day
one to capitol hill by the way that
means that if someone gets shot they can
sue a mom and
mom and pop gunshots that's really cool
just to be clear giving
even if they legally sold a gun and
someone happens to shoot someone so it's
the michael moore uh
blame kmart for columbine technique yeah
successful presence as a matter of fact
bernie even voted against that and
that's why he only got a
d minus from the nra as opposed to an f
like every democrat right
order it decide priorities
what needs to be done all right let's
listen to this the next major initiative
is
here comes and i'll be announcing it
friday in pittsburgh in detail
is to rebuild
the infrastructure both physical and
technological infrastructure in this
country
what is this so that we can compete oh
great
you know what you know what probably
happened he probably got some poll
results that said
hey guns are the losingest issue the
democratic party has stay away from it
joe's going to take me to pittsburgh
some of you have been around long enough
to know
i think he just forgot where he was did
he did he was not answering
did they not coordinate the questions
that they're supposed to ask him with
his sheet
there i think the majority of the
american people
don't like the fact that we are now
ranked what 85th in the world in
infrastructure i mean
look the future infrastructure what's he
talking about
the best airport's going to accommodate
is he trying to blame infrastructure
problems on people going out and
shooting bridges
i think he lost his place and pivoted to
like we're going to launch an
infrastructure plan
if someone can let me know in the chat
those who are mug club we'll be talking
with you afterwards yeah maybe we missed
what just happened
yeah he said colorado in atlanta
you promised the gun bill look here's
the thing with doctors things that
people don't like about donald trump
all of the qualities that people
disliked were the opposite of this
because he was a dog on a bone
and he would repeat himself ad nauseam
because he wanted to
lay into the report like no excuse me
excuse me
actually we're not we're not we're not
the top country in mass shootings no
excuse me look if you actually look at
the countries
okay we're not the top one excuse me
because of all the countries
there are top countries that are not
us okay no excuse me and i know you like
to say that with the top
i know that you love you would love to
say we're the top right well that's not
true
we're not one of them he would do it
just keep going yeah he didn't
lose his train of thought he stayed on
it and these things went four hours
biden can't last no one in five miles of
our house no they just asked for them
about
he's still talking about infrastructure
it's a hundred and eight years about the
slaughters in
in georgia and he's like oh pittsburgh's
got a nice airport
yeah well i mean at the very least it
could be like my thoughts and prayers
with the families and the victims like
he could have started with that but he
pivoted immediately to
where am i infrastructure uh that'll
we'll talk about that i can't hold a
train of thought for long enough to say
a prayer
still have lead pipes servicing the
water line our father who
art we have over a hundred you know the
thing well
it looks like he would be the conductor
on a ghost train
[Applause]
just pull up what are we doing
and by the way i don't know where to put
his mind what am i doing he would be
like
i don't know if it was a canadian show
but it'd be like if after they rotated
george carlin and ringo starr and
shining town station they'd
bring in biden the kids go this guy
um i want to hear the follow-up from
this guy like what
sir what the hell was that
[Applause]
sir sure
[Laughter]
i'm sorry did you hear me say gun bill
yeah did you hear me say
shootings i understand that
firearms sounds a lot like bridge no i
understand the infrastructure
of a bridge in airports are pretty good
yes you you get it you come back you get
it man you see what i'm saying
there's planes
there's only one of two answers here
okay there can and you guys tell me
people sometimes say well you have abs
yeah look i do have absolutist thinking
sometimes when something like this
happens
one of two reasons that that just
happened either a he completely lost his
train of thought he has no idea that the
question was about firearms
or number two he's gonna go along with
uh
pre-written talking points anyway
because they mutually agreed upon that
before the conference
and the guy stepped out of turn there is
no door number three lost his train of
thought
or has softballs from the media period
pick one you tell me what you think is
most likely could be [ __ ]
how many schools where the kids can't
drink the water out of the fountain
oh boy i thought he said schools i
thought for sure he was going to
shootings oh i thought so too well in
the chat make sure you get us some good
questions in the chat guys keep going
just let us know what you think he was
going for
our kids too don't have adequate
ventilation
how many swords are they going they're
going to they're doing their kumon
learning classes in barney frank's tip
basement i'm convinced we missed
the question something happened did we
miss a question
i don't know somebody let us know
because this doesn't sound like the
answer someone let us know because as i
understand it
pubic hair gingerbeard asked about the
recent shootings and he started
responding about infrastructure yeah
do i have that incorrect because i would
love
he asked about the manufacturer
liability that he promised on day one
it's not day one anymore that not that
he would know that but
well the only time a kid couldn't drink
out of a chat saying you guys are
siblings who came in on monday so nobody
follows up show me your nipple
phone number for their mother who lives
in the us we have contacted each other
that's the only way they know her kids
are here because somebody
got some clowns today
so when can we expect your promise of
things getting better
with contacting and experiencing well
they're already getting better but
they're going to get
real they've got a whole hell of a lot
better real quick we're going to hear
some people leaving
okay we can't even we can on these roads
i just talked about we're going to get
it done here we go we're not going to
need roads
higher that's a gas team and several
cabinet level officers
the other night we're going to be moving
within the next uh
within the next week over a hundred
thousand i mean
about a thousand people out of oh man
border patrol into safe secure beds and
facilities we're going to significantly
ramp up we're already out there
contacting everyone from getting some of
the employees at hhs
there's a lot of them doing other things
and move them into making those calls
we're in a we're in the process of
rearranging if this is his last question
the personnel needed this is very
clearly a recap
of the fact this is very clearly like
we're going to turn this is we're going
to do a callback question where i get to
wrap up
everything that i've said i've never
seen something more pre-packaged
due to a lack of trust in someone's
basic cognitive function
and i've worked with special needs kids
at churches there's ways to do that
and i don't say that as an insult to
them they're not you guys it is an
insult to
from dna to uh to birth certificates
which takes
longer so i want to do this as as
quickly boy that'd be 12 percent and as
safely as possible it needs a shot
well no treating the rude cows it causes
in latin america
things over
oh my god oh he's lost it i hope he
slugs her
he's talking there's no mic know he just
walks up and just you see a hand go into
her frame
as well what are you doing
you're looking for a nipple button i i
think i smelled finesse
guadalupe saying i got a great idea
let's sell
everything we have give it to a coyote
have them take our kids across the
border into a desert where they don't
speak the language
won't that be fun let's go
that's not how it happens people don't
want to leave
that's exactly how it is
they do want to leave even though you
dislike that donald trump said mean
things like these countries are
[ __ ] countries allegedly because
they're not as good as the united states
uh the fact is these countries are
inferior to the united states what do i
mean
in every way shape or form safety class
mobility
income uh uh i mean take your pick
name anything name any metric for a
country
no exactly the answer is no to all of
them so they want to leave and come to
the united states
that doesn't mean that everyone has the
right to the united states you cannot
say hey
we need to do away with nash nationalism
is bad not white nationalism
the idea of being proud in your nation
telling people that that is bad
and then say hey but no one wants to
leave but we need to let them in
yeah why would we want to let them into
a mediocre country
i got a lot of trunk space i could
probably make a few extra shillings
these days as a coyote
thousands of kids in these goddamn
facilities
really little babies crying all night
there's some that's true
that's what we got to act and yesterday
i asked
my team a lot of babies by the way this
is right now hey guys just at the end
let me riff a little bit yeah like
no i'm going to walk around the
microphone
if the baby is crying all night you just
shake it
everyone knows that press the top of its
head let's just give it a good ol
it's the bunch
[Music]
the good thing is with every infant
that's crying the top of their head
they have an easy button yeah much like
me
i wanna hear a question administration
with not considering the immigration
legislation that was passed in the house
until the situation at the border has
been resolved
no because i know they have to posture
for a while
they sort of got to get out of their
system speaking of posture
start working on yours joe
looking like a walking prawn mr burns
putting your ear into the microphone to
hear better who wants to help it's
really something solve the problem and
make make the situation better
but folks i'm going thank you very very
much
that's fascinating hey we really
followed the general rule of clothes
with your uh clothes with your
material no that was folks i got a poop
do you see him just staring into just a
cocoon
your wife climb a lot of trees just she
climbs one every once in a while
yeah all right hold on let's see let's
see the fawning by the way before we go
to the live fact check afterwards here
at cnn
look i think by any objective metric
people would have to say that was not
good that was bad
that was one of the worst eyes it's
it's so bad i i this guy has his eye
shot kennedy glasses
[Laughter]
it's so bad though donald trump did one
every single day at the start of
coronavirus oh this was and he would
interrupt
doctors like dr burke get the hell out
of the way this is my stance this is how
you answer
this is his like coming out and going
like this is why i didn't answer
questions before because i'm this
serious yeah what a strong start yeah
it's like dude you're drifting
10 minutes in he doesn't know what he's
doing i really want to see what they say
about the jesus he's like the tortoise
and the hair
if in addition to taking a nap the hair
also couldn't run
when he said joey bald eagles i knew he
had it
they're trying to get some reform in
place i had them eating out of the
palm of my liver spotted hands
and filibuster you need to i'm shocked
this was not somebody who was coming to
say
let's go we are going to break down the
filibuster i'm going to bash things up
in the senate because
priority x y and z must get through in
fact this was joe biden the same joe
biden we saw on the campaign trail
the same joe biden we've seen governing
for the last couple months he calls
himself
i'm a fairly practical guy he likes to
get things done i was hired to solve
problems
not create division and i thought what
was most telling
the last thing he said is republicans
have to posture by not thinking that we
send in record number of illegal
migrants
he reaffirmed where his position was on
those issues
but he said and i thought this was so
revealing
that presidencies succeed
by timing your priorities and how you
order things
and how you sequence things and he made
clear
his next thing is this build back better
infrastructure
this really is chauncey gardner if the
garden is healthy
the plant will grow oh so what you're
saying
is uh if we uh till the soil what was it
uh uh what's the name of the guy who was
uh on dirty work the dad in that
oh uh jack ward jack ward jack ward was
the president right yeah
for those of you haven't seen being
there with peter sellers it's a special
needs guy
who's a gardener yeah and he
accidentally becomes president
he says it and they ask him what are you
going to do with the economy he goes
well if the garden is healthy
the plant will grow and they're all
interpreting whatever he said
that's what they're doing right here
whether or not
house democrats can get their
legislation through
the senate which is also very narrowly
controlled
by democrats so it's using the word
filibuster sounds wonky and nerdy
and guilty as charged but the issue is
does that mean
climate change legislation gets through
does that mean
gun control legislation gets through or
not and i just want to talk about
priorities to help the american people
tangible things for people's lives
making sure that we increase the price
of gas he got an elephant asked a gun
question though and responded with a
talking point
it's not okay and you know where that
comes from right that comes from
that comes from being vice president the
last thing he can remember is being vice
president under
barack obama and when barack obama came
in he did his whole stimulus initiative
of
shovel-ready jobs right was all about
infrastructure that's why he's
remembering he's like i worked for the
uh
worked for the old uh worked for the old
uh colored folk
it'll work for me now look at biden's
quotes
i can't be racist if i'm actually doing
an impression of what would you rather
me uh
in person yeah 7-eleven uh uh you have
to have an indian accent or oh you know
what it's good to see finally an
articulate black man take this hey
go ahead cancel me where's the wide shot
go ahead cancel me
you ain't black thank you thank you
cancel me okay let's listen to them here
joe biden also wants to do voting rights
he spoke passionately about that he also
spoke passionately about
immigration and also about you are up
here drawing the line that black people
in the united states who in poll after
poll say
of course they can get voter id if you
say it's racist to expect them
to be able to procure identification you
are
absolutely disgracing people in your
community who she claims to represent
who have repeatedly no that's not true
yeah that's not true
and there there's study after study
after study we did this a segment on
this it's been debunked it was posted in
the washington post
every single study after that showed
that it was
no one in any community deemed it more
difficult to get an id
than a middle-class white person outside
of exclusively
spanish-speaking migrants and by the way
these studies didn't account for legal
status
yeah absolutely so one of the things
that ted cruz pointed out about hr
uh well it's not hr1 yeah it is hr1 he
said that if you
are an illegal immigrant on government
services if you get a check
you're automatically registered to vote
so think about that automatically
registered to vote and now it's illegal
to ask for an id
wow so it's like so hold on a second
they get our money
and then automatically get to cancel out
our vote yes it's like a multi-ethnic
spit roast
yeah in texas that's 95 000 people
95 000 people perfect
hey by the way we're about to stab dave
landau oh good we have an actual
by the way this is a real sword katana
blade real sword katana
really make sure you aim it properly
even brian oh good with his
don't move dave one arm yeah uh huh
a little harder just you know like
really rare back get it in there hey you
know what can you step back and jab
like joust him yeah joust yeah yeah
you feel any of that that's pretty good
no yeah it's totally good good give him
another one the last one just goes all
the way through i heard that
give it a little harder as long as it's
accurate yeah accuracy there you go
spartan armor systems.com promo code
crowder you get ten percent off
i wear them like my jammies they're so
comfy
like start wearing are they are they
going to bring out the fact check
do we have a fact check docker do we
pretty much all do it in real time uh
they'll bring it out okay all right
we'll have them bring it out let's watch
uh
felt like he wanted to do that yeah he
did he really told me he actually
steamed he volunteered
is it because i threw a coffee on well
it's more so that you can blow on it
first
well why would you hand me hot coffee
i didn't say that i wasn't complicit i
wanted i want my coffee luke
from abc i believe asked a question
about a young unaccompanied minor
standing at the border
uh president biden gave a humane answer
and he said no he would not
turn that un um unaccompanied minor away
he's waiting
didn't he say that he would he said he
said he would put a mother in that case
his mother who could be identified
because i remember we made the joke
about a drug dealer sounding like a mom
he said he would be sent back can
someone rewind that can someone loop
that back could someone pull that clip
because i'm pretty sure i remember him
saying that he would send that person
back and now
maybe it's not one of the agreed upon
answers and their talking points and now
santa's saying no he gave a humane
answer saying he wouldn't send him back
by the way he did it's the one thing i
liked about his whole press conference
maybe he didn't mean to say well if you
look at the other newscaster
who looks like every senator during the
mccarthyism
um he has the facial expression that
he's aware that guy is incorrect
yeah but he's just not calling him on it
yes it's like jake tapper can smell
farts and he's not allowed to let on
making it very clear that infrastructure
what he called a job spill
was going to be his next priority
talked about how one in five american
roads is in disrepair 180
000 miles how we rank something like the
u.s ranks something like 13th in the
in the world when it comes to
infrastructure china's spending three
times as much
is still developing the willingness and
just started republicans
by the way republican senators
everything else about china sucks yeah
do you think the
the average citizen of china you know
who doesn't live in some kind of a
royal palace that's been uh that's been
legacies in
do you think they'd take roads for the
bicycles that they put
90 pounds of baggage on or do you think
they'd take a decent income
you know or how about the ability to
have a bible in their nightstand without
their house being
burned with them and with them in it
alive like the church and patriot
i think they would opt for that rather
than paved roads and by the way i'm
pretty sure a lot of them are still dirt
yeah you know who cares zero about how
much money is being spent on roads in
china
the uyghurs that are being killed by the
chinese right now they i don't think
they care
right well all yeah that's all the
financial it's a little bit please don't
give them
any more sidewalks to kirby russ
infrastructure project that sounds like
a and this was really telling
he said if you prioritize you can
accomplish things as a president i was
just mesmerized that's what that guy was
saying and he pivoted to this so bad and
nobody is saying
he was asked a question about guns he
said nothing to the victim's family that
we heard
unless we like missed time got abducted
by aliens and dropped back all right
well listen before we before we give our
wrap
up here i don't know if we're not going
to get the fact check get a token now i
need it within about one minute or
otherwise it's useless i think i can
just go through here
but uh let's just compare that just mind
you let's compare
that press conference to what we saw
from the previous administration who by
the way
donald trump did him every day for
months and when he wasn't doing them
every day he was still doing them
consistently
let's compare what you just saw to the
kind of press conference that you would
see from donald trump and the media
treatment they're in
how do you see your role as a moral
leader mr president just how do you see
your role there's so many people i'm
sorry as a moral leader though
i i think i am a great moral leader and
i love our country
why are you pitting americans against
one another sir
is that how you view no i'm not citizens
of this i'll tell you what
we want a lot of elections last night we
did very well
last night but in many ways i think it's
going to happen i think it's going to
have a very positive
impact michael cohen recently said you
called black voters stupid
that's false omarosa has accused you of
using the n-word and the rapper
the rapper little john has said you
called him uncle tom what's your
response i don't know who little john is
i don't know how he was didn't he fight
his remarks no i would never do that and
i don't use racist remarks
mr president after three and a half
years you regretted all
all the lying you've done to the
american people all the lying all the
dishonesties
that who has done you have done
uh tensorflow go ahead please please
i am a young vibrant man
i look at joe i don't know about him i
don't know
all right young vibrant man too old yeah
that that seemed like the same kind of
treatment hey look nipple button lady is
back on cnn
by the way maybe put them here i asked
some questions and the answers were
silly
well you're fired but yeah but i wear my
hair like princess zelda what i like
about the trump conference is how it
wasn't nine people
sitting in chairs six feet apart or
wearing masks asking questions and
making sure going
page four yeah they're standing up like
they're selling stock trades
uh okay let me do a quick live fact
check here so there are a few things
that we've already talked about we
already talked about the modern border
sir we already talked about
gun control but something that he said
that the filibuster is a relic of the
jim crow era that's the claim that he
made
obamacare was only passed because of
budget reconciliation which prevented
republicans from using the filibuster
uh that's what i was saying earlier yeah
and uh biden said i think we have a clip
here right
yeah that biden said keep in mind that
he opposed abolishing the filibuster and
i know you're going to say well hold on
a second are you bringing something up
from his uh
disgraced presidential campaign in 1988
that he had to cancel due to serial
lying and corruption no no no this comes
from
march do we have the clip
yeah almost that was a dunk and you guys
hey look when i say do you have the clip
and you don't say the answer is
no did dukakis run in 88
uh i'm trying who it was i'm trying to
remember i think that sounds right yeah
it sounds right all right
was that a bush dukakis you know who did
i believe in 1988 anymore
joe biden
isn't she married to maury pose is
wasn't she married maury povich doesn't
surprise me isn't that correct do we
have the clip of him opposing
the abolishing of the filibuster well
i'm going to see him real
we have uh his communications director
talking about it okay in in march
this is right at the first claim here
recently he wants to work with
republicans to work with independents he
believes that
you know we're stronger when we build a
broad coalition of support
um and look i would say look at what
we've been able to do
in the first six weeks that we've been
in office with the filibuster in place
we just passed
a 1.9 trillion dollar rescue plan that's
going to make a
massive difference in the lives of
people all across the country you know
we've been able to but we were able to
get it done look it's a 50 50 senate we
understand that we are going to have to
navigate our way through a 50 50 senate
that's the that is the the uh you know
that's the situation
that we're facing but with the
reconciliation rates only require 50
votes i mean that that's how you're able
to do this
other bills you won't be able to do that
well but we also got it done with the
support of 75 of the american people
including over 50 of republicans
you know american voters who uh heard
president biden's uh
heard him lay out his proposal believed
that he had the right approach that this
was the right plan
all right unless this clip actually
involves biden saying he opposes so it
says here hey someone in the room their
interns if you guys want to keep
your 25 an hour which is very very much
nicer than that
yeah it's the first clip not clip h
it's the first one labeled clip and i
remember this clip that's why i
requested it
uh here's another one they claimed that
so just send it in there to the page
where you know that token island has
access to it it's right
here it says clip um they claimed a 31
percent
uh of migra there was a surge of 31
under donald trump that's another thing
we kind of gave you some general
statistics but here's something
that is specific thank you to choi
junior that actually happened with
unaccompanied minors
under joe biden last week was reported
that as many as 4 200
unaccompanied unaccompanied migrant
children were being held in short-term
holding facilities that's a 31 increase
so even the number they used
um so he was basically conflating it
right like this is terrible the 31 oh
that's me
well that's actually a good job done i
think yeah that's wonderful
and by the way when he was talking about
the uh he was talking about uh
the middle east look he bombed syria
right away so we were coming back from
arizona when i was there with the
mayo clinic and yes we had a driver who
was 31 days
as uh former president barack obama
would say iraqi
um and he at one point i like i said hey
sorry i can't i need to pull my mask it
was
my mask was below my nose he goes i
don't care you can take the mask off if
you want i don't believe in it i said
well you can take your mask off because
it's [ __ ] because the mask was only
needed kovid is over my friend
it's over because the election is over
you know
you know i said oh what do you mean he
goes listen i am from iraq okay
i served in the armed forces alongside
the american military in iraq okay
and we for four years had peace in our
country and now
that's over that's it that's over i used
to hate america i used to think i hate
america i could tell i came here
now i said well a second how many how
many of your uh how many of your
relatives are friends who are middle
eastern from iraq do you think
he goes before before trump was
president
90 hated him now it's 80 percent agree
with me
because i am right they know that i am
right because
they had peace for four years and they
said okay we've never had this
yeah i mean from the party who is
anti-war who protested the vietnam war
like
they had no other thing to do in life
they sure are willing to stay in wars
and not willing to make a commitment you
know what donald trump did he put out a
goal
like a leader does and says figure out
how to make this happen because on may
2nd
the bases will be empty don't give me
any bull crap
get it done and it happens right with
biden i don't know how to do it oh this
is another one i didn't know the actual
number but i'm glad that we got it uh
biden said that uh every day americans
built america and unions built them
by the way that's not i don't know if
washington and jefferson
i don't know if they were in the
carpenters union i'll have to think back
to you
maybe john adams because he liked his
pipe um
killed at least 11 000 11 thousand union
jobs
alone in the keystone pipeline yeah yeah
that's what the experience was
higher gas prices oh yeah don't you
understand well no
and he said he wouldn't do that in the
campaigns right
people in pennsylvania right now are
really happy that he supports unions
because they can't afford to even pay
their dues anymore because they don't
have jobs they're i'm sure they're happy
and dr levine killed their grandparents
ah yes that's true
and like i said yeah middle-income
middle-class income helps average
up 5 thousand under donald trump only
one thousand under obama uh this is one
where they're saying oh yeah we have
this clip i love it we're straight from
the uh
uh uh uh i'm trying to think i was i
can't say horse because you said that
don't say that
something straight from the would be
beautiful and brave migrants yes yeah
mask
uh the immigrants
joe biden said are coming because you
know he's a nice guy no he didn't say it
the reporter said right that's because
that's how you were seen what is a
humanitarian
you were seen as a more as a decent man
right buzzfeed boldly she said
that's why you were elected because you
were seen as a decent
uh a good man and he said yeah
yeah um and of man that whittles
unfortunately he accidentally stabs
himself with the knife
yes and then his uh forgets to train his
dog so he attacks kids on a white house
tour
i told you don't go don't go in the west
wing cujo's there
well you know you did you have to name
him cujo joe that was kind of
it's foreshadowing steinbeck did it oh
[Laughter]
so he said that she said that they were
coming because he's a decent man i think
we have the clip right here from
an illegal immigrant themselves saying
that of course they knew that trump
wouldn't let them in and this is why
they're coming now
would you have tried to do this when
donald trump was president
definitely not definitely so did you
come here because joe biden was elected
president
basically basically oh he can't be
expected to know what he's he's mexican
that's fighting says no understanding
that his policies made it likely
that people would be able to come here
get into this country and not be forced
to leave
yeah donald trump knew how to keep
people out you show up at the border
we're sending you back
if you're a criminal you're getting put
in jail if you commit a crime and you're
an illegal we're sending you back right
after you serve your sentence baby or
you're going to a mexican prison
it's almost as though if you stop
punishing crime
more people will commit yeah exactly
that's too complicated for joe he can't
well we'll draw him back of a children's
menu
well i don't buy it and by the way his
own porters are roberta jacobson
admitted that the policies were driving
smugglers and criminals uh to cross the
border yeah
it's a coincidence that as soon as trump
and his immigration policy were
on the way out and biden and his stated
policy were on the way in
this historic surge at the border
started
well first of all one of the things i
think is important is we've seen surges
before
surges tend to respond to hope
is going to come
after four years of you know pent up
demand
so i don't know whether i would call
that a coincidence but i certainly think
that
the idea that a more humane policy would
be in place
may have driven people to make that
decision
but perhaps more importantly it
definitely drove smugglers
to why she's smiling i know that's not a
good thing
does information about what was now
possible
and we know that if the changing
administration's brought hope
then from your perspective he's a
sociopath good
but i don't know if that's what i just
said i think it's a reflection of how
migrants feel at a particular time
well why do you think they feel that
it's gonna send more smugglers
and so ladies of el paso yeah i hope you
like
uninvited penetration can you imagine
working in communications in the white
house trying to like push over the
security to get in the room and take her
off the map
take the mic away
secret service agents are [ __ ]
talking again
she's laughing about smugglers does she
think that's an important voting demo
she's just excited because there's a
chance she's going to be touched again
after 10 years
even joe biden stopped grabbing my
buttons oh
that's why i wore this yellow jacket oh
that's a really poor placement of
buttons by the way the first two colors
to draw attention are black and yellow
that's why i dressed like a school bus
look at me i look like i'm the flock of
seagulls
now
oh my gosh remember bananarama
oh okay uh by the way all you mentioned
the code but let me just hit this
briefly all the covets success it all
comes from donald trump yeah just to be
clear was it
1.3 million uh of vaccines were
delivered in january he was doing a
million a day
america's already on track for 100
million in a hundred days
biden said he could do 200 million in
100 days um well again
thanks to donald trump he's he's halfway
there uh he hasn't
increased it uh dramatically at all i
also love that you know the only answer
he had on the border crisis
was well kamala's gonna do it yeah
you know kamala's gonna do it so listen
if
she's in charge let's hear what she has
to say yeah
do you plans to visit the border
um not today
but um i have before and i'm sure i will
again
it's so crazy and by the way thanks for
letting us know yeah it does turn out we
weren't wrong we thought
here joe biden is the one thing that he
does really well and then i want to go
to what
you know your recap he's so crazy
he makes you think you're crazy yeah
because we're all sitting going wait
true they asked a gun question there's
no way but then you're going there's no
way that the sitting president of the
united states would answer a gun
question with a bridge
we must have missed something because we
like double off and we were having many
so there must be something that we
missed so that's a skill
joe biden is so insane that he makes all
of us question our
own train of thought and you know what
maybe he really is playing 12d
chess i don't think so no
no it's foursquare
uh okay before what are your thoughts uh
gerald on how this went
uh so i'm not surprised by joe biden
obviously right we all thought that he
was going to have a difficult time doing
an
actual press conference i'm also not
surprised by the questions because we
thought it was going to be softballs i
am
shocked that nobody else called him on
the gun question thing i am i mean just
absolutely shocked and also the other
thing that the press was just screaming
about was like the press has to be freed
right you're suppressing the press under
president trump
yeah they said when can we go into these
facilities
and he's like well whenever we could
make it look better that was
i swear to you i'm not quoting verbatim
but he's like well after a few days when
we get people out of there and things
will be better
and so when can we go in well i'm not
sure yet it's like
we got to bleach the sheets and get some
sherman in there yeah when i can bring a
black light
yeah when i make when i can make this
situation not look bad for me
then i'll let the press enter right
that's what joe biden which by the way
parallels this very press conference
it's when i think
i have enough to sort of i'll finally do
a press conference right a very measured
controlled way where i give you the
questions that you can ask me
right and he still couldn't find a spot
right well and the other the last thing
that i was surprised about was that
and i told you this was probably what he
was going to come out with some strong
policy thing to kind of
take the trajectory of it in that
direction he came out with 200 million
vaccines like
your bill it's like oh we're gonna do a
hundred million you get in there like
what we've already done 87 because of
donald trump well
crap what 200 million like that's not a
strong policy initiative no
come out with something better and
that's what you came with if you left
him in a room with all the
ingredients for a vaccine he wouldn't
come out with a vaccine
all it would say is peel back tape to
have vaccines
with the vaccine and an empty syringe
with instructions on how to fill it
he'd come out missing an eye yeah or you
just have a air bubble headed for his
heart
just come out with his hematoma i don't
know what's that you press it
and he faints he didn't miss anything
the only thing he's made is a bowel
movement that's the only thing that
which is difficult and he comes out and
he has to blow out candles
i use the needle to draw blood and i
drew up a plan for infrastructure
what about the roads the roads there's
uh
guys guns and bridges
hey whoa come on i'm not kidding her
sometimes the criminals
they put their guns under the bridges
and we don't know because we're not
spending money on those bridges
how are we going to find the guns hunter
hunter took by the car
and uh drove onto the bridge and
somebody sold them something great song
with the
peppers the chili guys yeah you like
them to the bridge give it away give it
away now we give all of them they put
their penises in socks
that's not that's not a sock sock isn't
an eight-year-old no
suck or something you put your foot in
ugh i mean
not your penis what come on put your
foot in it even a penis suck which i
make
yeah in china even a penis joe bites
penis sucks
build that better
oh my gosh do you think i'd endorse it
if i didn't believe in it
come on come on come on i got real soft
balls
not just questions but in real life and
if i put this penis guard on it joe
biden's penis sock guard
i'm not going to hurt my softballs
what's what's your uh what's your take
what's your take away from uh
by the way the promo code is dementia
we're not insinuating anything you got
20
off mug club it's the only reason we're
allowed to do this and by the way we are
going to go and take your chat
on club lotto cutter.com mug club uh
that's our you know because we don't do
the youtube chat and this doesn't run on
facebook anymore because they always
remove it but uh before we go what
what was your over your macro impression
of this oh man i thought he was coherent
fluid i thought everything made sense um
what i really think
um for years and years and years we've
dealt with politics
and letting people run us instead of us
controlling them the way that we should
uh trump who i had my own issues with
was a monkey wrench into the system
where at least you got somebody
doing something and giving something
back to the press
this is what we voted for uh to put in
the same business as usual [ __ ] we
were so worried about demonizing the
last guy
that we didn't even pay attention to
what we were sneaking in
you have him and you have kamala who's
somebody where you didn't even read the
ingredients you just looked at the label
all we've done is label us and destroy
this country
this is dog [ __ ] and we should be
ashamed
that it's in office that's what i truly
and honestly think what are you going to
bring major into this
i didn't mean to i didn't mean to say
come on i'm just mad like talk about
kamala
nowhere he's back in chevy chase
maryland come on speaking of chevy chase
did you see me do the fall
yeah trying to get into an airplane i
fell up yeah it's fine the turn on the
floor
turns out for it to be considered a
sketch it can't be real yeah
i uh you're a lion dog face pony soldier
uh no i think i was going up the stairs
in my electric chair
and uh it's it stalled out and i tumbled
down i thought i would get up fast
like the old lady in gremlins oh i
wouldn't go out the sunroof
there was piss everywhere my knees were
bleeding
listen listen listen the first time i
fell
okay that was an accident but time
number three you can't blame it how's my
piss it gets slippery
piss on carpet look like i will say that
i think that's actually a great point i
grabbed the spot shot
that's a great point that i honestly
believe that and i would take it one
step further and i would say before we
go here to mud club i think it's really
when he's talking about look
look at the policies that he's talking
about when he says look it's time for uh
for uh us to come together and what he
means is uh for everyone to get on board
with the democrats and he's talking
about it's time to get this business
done look or to keep us completely
divided that's what he means by come
together right that's what he means he
really means is come along to get along
otherwise we're just going to run
roughshod over you now who does he plan
over whom does he plan to run roughshod
well let's be clear letting in tens of
thousands of migrants record numbers
right
at the border taking guns away even
though he didn't actually have the
mental acuity to go over that we know
what he supports as far as policy
increasing taxes all right all of these
issues that he's talking about uh
for when he talked about coven no
solutions to really actually ending
lockdown so when he says
hey we need to come together what he
means is him his democratic buddies in
the house
in the senate and of course the media
who offer up softball questions and i
can't confirm or deny that they seemed
agreed upon ahead of time but the fact
that he kept looking down
and seemed to answer them in sequence
and then was given a nice little wrap-up
question
makes me think that it happened so now
we have all
and branches we have all branches of
government we have the mainstream media
we of course have hollywood and we have
big tech
trying to do their bidding right these
people all
are coming together to make sure that
the flow of information supports the
policies
of disarming you while letting a record
number of migrants come into this
country
with with which with which we have no
system
to verify right wherever they are
whenever they are and then reducing the
voting age to 16 and not requiring
any kind of identification so when they
talk about who needs to come together
they're talking about just as dave
landau said business as usual
the elites so that they can enact
policies
against you it really is that's the one
thing that i would say donald trump did
really pretty well and i was more of a
libertarian conservative
uh for a long time and i still am really
that's how i would be labeled but
i do think my eyes were open certainly
to the more
uh pervasive problem of just how bad it
is for career politicians to constantly
have carte blanche to write checks with
your money
because they have no concern for your
well-being they have concerns solely
with votes this is what this is why we
need term limits because now
they're running it for job security and
not to actually serve
their population just compare joe biden
let me leave you with this comparison
okay
everything that i hate about joe biden
can be summed up in a comparison to
george washington and i don't think that
we've had another president more
comparable to george washington or
modern times than donald trump and
here's what i mean
joe biden for 48 years suckled at the
taxpayer t
he's never held a job in private office
for 48 years
george washington was the first
president and so beloved that he could
have stayed president
likely for decades he had the power of
the world's greatest nation keep in mind
a world a country sorry that had left
the world superpower the world's
greatest superpower
only a decade only a few years prior to
become the world's greatest super
superpower only a couple decades after
and he was given the keys to that
kingdom and they said by the way no
one's going to give you the boot please
please stay
and he walked away is there any more
clear of a contrast than a man who
walked away from that power
versus a man who has been clamoring for
it and claiming
credit for it for 48 years which man do
you think is most likely
to serve you that's that was my takeaway
from this press conference all right
we're gonna go to mug club and take your
chat
live with credit.com mug club and uh the
promo code is dementia not insinuating
anything you get 20
off uh we will see you of course next
monday
uh and right now youtube thank you not
really piss off